first of all let me start by saying
congrats on the first two episodes and
they were so well done but before I ask
you some specifics I have to switch and
say I'm I love big mouth you're a voice
on that yeah and so I want to ask what's
it like being a part of that and and
does it ever get old people talking
about almost famous good question
big mouth is it's a lot of fun for me to
be a show on that because you know I act
opposite Paul Scheer who I was on the
league with and I'm being directed and
led by Nick Kroll who I was on the
league with that was all of our first
jobs in television and so we've all
remained very very close and we all sort
of guest on each other's projects and I
mean leave it to Nick Kroll to find a
way to make you know a crass animated
show about puberty be oddly sensitive
and moving the cultural conversation
forward I saw my first episode I'm so
glad you brought it up and I didn't even
know you were in it I'm just like a
guest here I almost saw my first episode
a friend of mine this past week and we
were having a big reunion of all phrases
like we were talking about kids and we
have 15 year olds and they were like
well you have to see this and we started
watching and it's absolutely Chris it's
that scale and no it never gets old
it won't get old to be talking about
having been on the morning show either
people I'm about to jump in on this we
just say there are a few times and you
as you get older you begin to recognize
when you're a part of something that has
serious ambition how it turns out nobody
ever knows but you know when almost
famous came out it came out it didn't
make a whole lot of money and so it has
grown over a period of time because of
whatever authenticity Cameron Crowe
added to it and Carrie Aaron Jen Michael
Reese I mean they may have put some
authenticity into this and rigor in a
way that I think yeah that's pretty cool
hopefully it lasts yeah one of the
things that I thought was so well done
about the first two episodes is that the
scripts are just so good and it when it
starts the opening shot is basically you
and you just jump into the world
no exposition dumps it's so you know so
well done can you talk about the quality
of the writing and what people can look
forward to over the course I guess with
the season yeah I mean I found
writing it wants to be incredibly
propulsive in terms of driving that
narrative forward leaving you those
breadcrumbs that make you keep wanting
for more in my experience that type of
storytelling often comes at the expense
of really good human dialog scenes they
don't tend to coexist and that was my
first impression I stepped into this and
said oh my god they got it both we're
gonna do the humanity we're gonna do the
personal and they're gonna pump this
narrative and they're gonna do it with
absolute narrative precision and you
just don't see it and we're gonna take
on every facet of one of the more
complicated social stones we've tried to
craft this one is really complicated for
people to understand and there are
people on all sides of this narrative
and when you're talking about power
structure and the dynamics in the
workplace and how we create a level
playing field it really hard to be
humane about it because people feel a
sense of urgency or a sense of
protective power and they want to stomp
on any of the nuance so to take on every
single character with that level of
humanity seems impossible and yet
somehow I feel like she's just done it
congratulations can't wait to finish up
the show thank you so much for giving me
your time